Brasil la mayor democracia de América
Latina y una de las más antiguas de la
región irá Entonces a las urnas este
domingo 2 de octubre en unos comicios
generales que tienen polarizado a todo
el país y que dejó una campaña plagada
por la desinformación los candidatos que
aspiran a la Silla presidencial son 11
pero son dos los que lideran todas las
encuestas el actual presidente Jair
bolsonaro y el ex mandatario Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva analizamos
entonces con gallo mañanelli el
constructor político y director de la
asociación brasileña de consultores
políticos cayó Gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de viernes en
directo América de Francia 24 hablemos
para dar un contexto del panorama
general Cómo llega Brasil a estas
elecciones generales
buenas Buen día Raúl buen día a todo
audiencia
llegamos de cierta manera bastante
decididos tenemos una un grado de
decisión de Voto bastante elevado ya se
puede tener por lo menos algo de
seguridad de que nula será el primer
colocado en las elecciones en la primera
vuelta y volvemos al tema que es silula
logra llegar o no a ganar las elecciones
en la primera vuelta o si vamos a tener
un babotaje aún no es una seguridad que
Lula pueda lograr esta en segunda vuelta
calle Le quiero preguntar a quién podría
definir el voto hablando de población
Tenemos también en cuenta de los
indecisos las personas que votaron en
blanco que este año si van a las urnas
podrían también ser determinantes en
Quién sería el nuevo presidente de
Brasil
pensado que tenemos una realidad un poco
distinta de lo que ustedes tienen
Colombia ustedes tienen una
participación de 50 por ciento por medio
de la población en las elecciones en
Brasil tenemos una participación más
elevada es uno de los países de América
Latina después de Argentina que tiene
una gran participación hablamos de 75%
por ahí de participación Así que
son pocos ahora mismo primer punto es
que el voto blanco y el voto nulo no
estaba fuera del conteo de lo que puede
significar la victoria en primera vuelta
Ese es el primer tema Entonces si la
gente se va para votar blanco nulo esto
no nos va a ser diferencia sobre Quién
va a ganar en primera vuelta segunda
vuelta el segundo tema es que hay de
hecho una parcela muy pequeña de votos
indecisos y lo que el último debate ha
traído era justamente la preocupa
del grupo de bolsonaro especial de
bolsonaro y su candidato naranja de
seguir
marcando
las Los motivos del rechazo a Lula y al
final de las cuentas acabaron dejando
marcada para una más los motivos de
rechazo bolsonar se lo que está pasando
es un fenómeno de gente que de verdad
está migrado al voto útil tejernos de
votar e incido en especial para votar en
Lula claro hablemos ahora de el actual
mandatario Joel bolsonaro quien Busca su
reelección en estas elecciones del
domingo Cayo el cuenta con pues amplio
respaldo de varios sectores dentro de
las fuerzas armadas y también como lo ha
dicho durante toda su campaña pues ya
está cantando que podría haber fraude
electoral si él pierde las elecciones en
Brasil Que tan fortalecido y qué tan
creíble y transpa es el sistema
electoral brasileño porque el mandatario
bolsonaro está ya cantando Aires de un
posible fraude electoral
Raúl te pongo de regreso a la pregunta
qué tan creído que tan creíble y que
estén fortalecido está el presidente de
la república para cuestionar el sistema
electoral que lo ha elegido en 2018
claro entonces Y es que ahí digamos es
un arma de doble filo callo porque eso
lo digo porque entonces si el presidente
venezolano llegaría a ganar elecciones
el domingo ahora sí tenemos entonces en
Brasil un sistema electoral fortalecido
y transparente pero si no lo gana no lo
es como es visto esto dentro de Brasil
el tema es que bolsonador está
cuestionando incluso las elecciones que
le ha elegido entonces comprende no no
tiene sentido por sonar está hablando
que el sistema electoral Incluso en 2018
cuando él se eligió estaba mal
está mal lo que pien solucionar lo que
propaga bolsonar lo que está pasando es
justamente esto como es un líder que
está intentando crear una ola de
violencia entre la población y una ola
de
desconformidad con todo que siempre Fue
suficiente para la gente quedarse
tranquila y elegir sus sus mandatarios
el sistema electoral de Brasil tiene Sí
algunas vicisitudes pero no llega ni
cerquita a la magnitud de lo que es que
lo que bolsonaro dice sobre el apoyo a
las de las fuerzas armadas
hay de cuestionar también porque este
apoyo no es general y descrito hay
muchas fuerzas y muchas
sectores muchos sectores la fuerzas
armadas que no destruyen el acuerdo con
lo que bolsonaron está haciendo de
verdad quizás nidos apoyadores de
bolsonaro que se mantienen ahí están
totalmente en acuerdo con la manera que
bolsonaro sigue intentando mantener el
grupo bueno es que no te no intenta pero
de la manera como más bolsado sigue
representando el país entonces existe
ahí sí una vergüenza bastante fuerte
de las fuerzas armadas en relación al
líder que ellos mismos eligieron para
ser presidente Cayo la policía del
supremo tribunal Federal son también
otros de los actores hay claves en lo
que ha sido toda esta campaña de Cara a
las elecciones el día domingo el máximo
tribunal particularmente con el juez
Alexandre demurá es que ha servido
Digamos como un contrapeso a el
presidente Yahir bolsonaro Y ante todo
esto también hay sectores que dicen que
este poder este tribunal se estaría
extralimitando en sus funciones en su
poder qué tan cierto es esto y qué tan
protagonista ha sido el tribunal y la
policía en esta campaña
Mira
dejamos una cosa bastante Clara sí la
policía la policía
y el tribunal no están directamente
ubicados lo que lo que vos estás
haciendo referencia es lo que ha hecho
Alexa con el tema de la filtraje de
mensajes de los exactamente ese caso sí
Alejandro no no debería hacerlo
como se equivocó de una manera Absurda
como pasó ahí de verdad de sus límites
pero
tampoco es algo que que llega a
[Música]
crear o perjudicar algo como las
elecciones quiero decir
Alejandra lo hizo justamente como
dijiste para contrarrestar lo que son
las actitudes
en términos dictatoriales y y de y
autoritarios y Alejandra que tampoco es
una persona
equilibrada en el sentido general tiene
ahí un rompente autoritario pero fue un
caso de estado acordate cuando hablamos
de un tribunal no estamos hablando solo
de su presidente tenemos un cuerpo de
juristas ahí un cuerpo de magistrados
que también hacen parte de lo que es la
decisión y la defensa de las
instituciones Así que lo que pasó con
Alexander y morais no puede ser súper
valuado así como sé estamos se está
haciendo